so in the last video we talked about
Oilers formula and then we showed the
expressions for how to extract a cosine
and a sine from Euler's formula and we
have a powerful set of expressions there
for relating Exponential's to sine waves
so now I want to show you an example
just a preview of when we get to the
formal AC analysis how we're going to
exploit these these expressions how we
going to exploit these formulas this is
a real-world signal this cosine term
let's suppose we build something that
has a cosine to it that could be
something like a microphone that's
hearing sounds that look like sine waves
and we would model those sine waves as a
cosine wave and they come in to some
electronics system so let me draw a
sketch of the clever approach that we're
going to use so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to build here's a circuit I'm
imagining there's there's resistors and
there's capacitors and there's inductors
linear elements and we can have sources
and stuff like that so there's something
in here and we have something going in
and something coming out okay voltages
and currents coming out voltage and
current coming in so I'm going to drive
my circuit with some sort of sinusoidal
I'll call that sinusoidal give it an
amplitude and I'll call it cosine of
Omega T and Omega is the frequency T is
time a is the amplitude of the signal
coming in here now that signal is going
to go into this circuit here something's
going to happen and there's going to be
a voltage or coming out of here so we'll
get V out over here of some sort and
it's going to be some amplitude and it's
going to be some sort of a cosine wave
of Omega T plus some phase angle some
angle that's that's our job to discover
this that's the the circuit analysis
problem for AC analysis we put in an AC
signal we're going to get out another AC
signal this is the forced response
remember it's going to look like the
input
it's going to be at the same frequency
but it's going to be at some different
phase angle so in order to do this
there's a fair amount of hard
trigonometry we have to do there's going
to be a lot of a lot of cosines and
sines and angles and things inside this
so that's pretty challenging analysis
now what we do with Euler's formula is
we turn it into Exponential's and we
already know how to solve Exponential's
so we take the same circuit it has the
same stuff inside as resistors and
capacitors the same exact circuit let's
draw the same exact circuit there that's
identical and it has the same outputs
output port right here and this time
what we're going to do is we're going to
basically take this cosine and we're
going to make up in our head we're going
to cast this into an exponential and the
way we do that is we use that formula we
use Euler's formula and we basically
create two sources two separate sources
and they're exponential sources this is
going to be a over to e to the J Omega T
that's this source here and this source
here is a over 2 e to the minus J Omega
T that's this waveform and if I add
those together like that now remember
the preview the equation we just looked
at Oilers formula says the cosine equals
that the voltage here is exactly the
same and all we've done is described the
same exact cosine waveform as these two
imaginary Exponential's now I can't
actually on my workbench build one of
these things these don't exist in in
real life but they can exist
mathematically they can't exist in my
head and I know that if I add these two
voltages together that I do get a cosine
so in our heads and on paper we can
actually drive circuits with these
things we can actually build it but on
paper we can do it and now that I have
two sources I can use the principle
superposition this is another use of the
very powerful idea of superposition so
using the idea of superposition I'm
going to apply each of these two inputs
one at a time and then add the results
together so over here I'm going to get
two outputs I'm going to get a V out one
let's call a V out Plus which is what
happens when I put in this plus source
and I suppress this one which means I
short it out I'm going to get a V out
plus and how do you solve a differential
equation when you have a exponential
going in well we know this it's going to
be an exponential answer it's going to
be some constant times e to the J Omega
T plus some constant some angle and then
I'm going to solve it again I'm going to
add to that V out - and I do that by
suppressing this input and turning this
one back on using superposition and V
out for the plus or sorry V out for the
for this source here is going to equal
some other K let's call that K plus in K
minus e to the minus J Omega T plus V so
I'm going to put in two Exponential's
I'm sure I'm going to get out two
Exponential's and now using Euler's
formula we know how to combine these we
can use that same expression and we can
recover our cosine we can recover the
real signal and this will have some
magnitude B we don't know the magnitudes
yet but we know what the shape of the
waveform is and if we look at this this
is the same thing as this here and we
did it by decomposing our cosine in two
Exponential's putting each exponential
through this and then recombining to get
cosine and we do all those steps because
solving differential equations with
Exponential's is the easiest way to do
it so just that you know it's not twice
as much work what's going to
happen is going to turn out that this
whole solution down here using the
negative using the negative exponential
if the answer is going to be exactly the
same as the positive exponential except
for there's just this conjugate this
complex conjugate in here so for real
signals going in the answer goes through
and it's always this these answers are
always complex conjugates of each other
as long as we start with a real input
okay so that was a review of Euler's
equation and a little preview a little
sneak preview of how we're going to do
AC analysis using this really powerful
tool